I'm washing my underwear and sink
because I didn't bring enough this time
around this shipwreck sinks hi guys it's
Friday and it's Grace and I have an
announcement to make
Oh what like that I got ski slope on the
top of my head what's happening Who am I
she dragged herself up yeah I can do it
pretty so I told you guys before that
August 1st was going to be the day that
I make an announcement and it is the day
I'm making an announcement and it
elsewhere we made time to announce
something can't spell announced without
okay I'm just going to get into it the
announcement is that I am
and it's an expedited birth look here
comes the baby oh oh it's beautiful
okay the real announcement is that I
grace Helbig and engaged imma see the
ring
the real nouns man is that I thought
it's appropriate to finally talk to you
guys about my significant other maybe
mine you know cool one okay I'm just
gonna I make it come in the real nails
mine is that I actually wear a wig
just getting the real announcement is
that I and actually a wig
I'm a member of the Whig party just get
it okay
the announcement is that I am taking
three months off for making YouTube
videos
um
just get there okay here's the real
announcement and this is on to say this
is not a joke and I know it's gonna take
a second for you to relax and it's not a
joke because I didn't set this up well
at all starting on Monday I will be
doing three videos a week instead of
five hold and there's no just kidding
that is the ROO announcement and I
thought by mini saying taking three
months off would lessen the blow of me
saying that I'm only doing three videos
a week instead of five it's only for a
trial period right now I just feel
insanely busy I feel like the quality of
my videos isn't up to my personal
standards and so to rectify that I think
focusing on three videos a week instead
of five will be more helpful to myself
and my emotional and mental health and
also to you guys I think you will enjoy
the quality of the videos a lot more
here's how it's gonna break down I will
be doing videos Monday Wednesday and
Friday
every week Monday videos are going to
get really good in a couple weeks and
stay tuned for that I'm really excited
about the future of Monday but for now
it's gonna be a little all over the
place Wednesday videos are gonna be kind
of an amalgamation of talking back to
you and reviews and how to's all just on
that one day but rotate it and then
Friday's gonna go back to being friary
it's been really hard to do friary while
we're shooting hey USA because we shoot
a lot of stuff ourselves for the show
and anything that I would shoot on my
camera for the week would be spoilers to
that show so I haven't been shooting
that much so the show is going to be
ending soon
hey USA please go check it out if you
haven't you - Drock concise - nice one
is TV so I'll be going back to giving
you guys for a diary every Friday and
that's that I'm really excited about it
and I hope that you guys are too I know
y'all hate change
92 really weighs my wallet down
hmm but it's happening and I just ask
that you deal with it
nothing really changing that much use up
two days a week that you had to find
something else to do for five minutes of
your time thank games for being awesome
and excited and cool towards me as a
human being and I'm just she pumped for
what is happening in the future also
there's a lot of other cool things going
on that
I wish I could tell you about everything
going on in my life and I can't because
excuse me man
Gracie's guy book.com thanks for are now
filtering tickets down below we're
organizing some really special guest
droppings for these shows that are gonna
be really awesome so please go buy your
tickets now